thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with fabiano carano fabiano first of all
you are playing black how did you
approach this game
yeah i felt like
i would take it
solidly i mean jeffrey is a player who
almost always goes for a fight um it's
not in his nature to back down
so i figured that we would get a fight
maybe i would get some chances but if
it's a draw
um
then it's also
it's also a fair result
and i felt like i was under pressure
out of the opening he knew the line
quite well
i didn't and um let's look uh through
the game actually yasser so we have the
position after e5 already at this point
i was
feeling that white was for choice uh
after move uh bishop c4 we're looking at
bishop f5 uh jeffrey actually played the
move queen c2 and take it away if abby
you were saying that you were feeling
under pressure yeah i i was expecting
bishop c42 or at least thinking that was
the most natural move yeah but after
bishop g4 very often my bishop will come
back either to f7 or queen d7 and bishop
to e6 later and uh once i trade this
bishop off i don't have any problems
okay so i think his plan was
was more dangerous
and i i think it was some sort of
maybe not direct preparation but he knew
the ideas of the position and this was
the main idea that the bishop on e4 is
so annoying for me it can't really get
kicked out because f5 will always
crumble my center
so
yeah so i'm saddled with this
weak king side
on the other hand
his only real pawn break is d4 and once
he does that very often it leads to a
lot of simplifications were you at any
point concerned about the pawn break via
h4 h4 h5 no not really because i figured
that anytime he plays eight well let's
say he does it before castling which is
um i think he was playing rook d1 with
the idea to stay flexible with his
with his king so he might have the
option of h4 but let's say he does it
here and i can play even queen d7
and h5 g5 my bishop will go to d6 i'll
castle short
yeah my king is a bit weaker but he took
a lot of time
and once he castles short his h pawn
will will be a weakness
and now he also has to contend with some
g4 stuff so
so i wasn't worried about this at all i
didn't expect it
i thought how he played just maybe he
should have castled instead of d1
uh keeping the rook more flexible maybe
he'll go to c1 because we saw later in
the game
that his rook went back to c1 and he
effectively
lost the tempo
so if he had done this and maybe rooks
he won here it would have probably been
a better version
uh something like
yeah or queen b1 like he played you know
just trying to prepare d4 you're right
it's it's maybe a tiny bit better for
white but it's not
it also wasn't overly concerning
it was a nice uh moment exactly here and
we we really liked your move
uh
where is it d4
excuse me uh it was the move right here
c4 we we thought that that was a very
important move that if you do take on d4
that white gets something something yeah
it will be a bit unpleasant if i take
everything and
my king side is a bit weak but when i
played queen f7 i had this idea in mind
c4 and the main point is if after c4 he
plays let's say rook after d1
trying to to play d5 win a piece i'll
play 97 i happily sacrificed the b7 pawn
uh
because my piece has just become so
active rook b8 see i'll regain the pawn
most likely
and um
his pieces are kind of bad suddenly
bishop on c3 and i don't have three
so
so here black would probably be fighting
for an advantage that's why i think we
saw what happened in the game exactly
and what happened was
uh jeffy played d5
and
everything just essentially came off uh
fabi the cleaning lady
yeah
and uh draw agreed
in terms of your experience against
jeffrey in rapid chess how do you guys
match up
we haven't had too much experience uh
playing against each other
i i only remember
one rapping blitz tournament here in st
louis that's what i was thinking too
um i i don't remember the results
[Laughter]
a lot of chats and then we played some
um
some games in the online rapid
tournaments that have been organized
recently right um but those are you know
very few games so we're still relative
newcomers to uh to this rapid chats
against each other we'll go get you prep
and thank you for joining us thank you
thank you favi uh it is time to see the
ray robson game we have to go straight
into it against lavon ironian as we see